yo this video is sponsored by
Squarespace make your next move what's
good y'all this week on thug notes we
crackin up with One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest by Ken Kesey hey he's wag
is usual up in the nut house where we
getting the dl from our huge as narrator
team brown do been surviving in this
trap two years by faking like he don't
speak and can't his teeth laying low
like he do when wild ads white boy
Randall McMurphy come rolling in Mac may
seem like he's curly in the head put on
a real you just putting up a front it's
winking kickin in the loony bin instead
of doing hard labeling the slam
ain't nothing tickle McMurphy's balls
more than raising hell and sticking it
to the man and up in here
the man is Nurse Ratched a hard-ass she
beats who runs the war with an iron fist
and a perfect pair today's no no for
real man page 11
they say she got some nice boobs despite
being a babyface busy with a soft voice
girls swinging the biggest dick in the
ward ratchet running these boys lives
like they ain't nothing but her puppets
she forced him to pop pills on a daily
she's apt their brains with electroshock
treatment talk smack right to their
faces and pit him against each other
doing therapy and even lobotomize ism
when they step out of line
damn mack daddy ain't gonna let this
[ __ ] do his boys like that so brother
mess with Nurse Ratched head by [ __ ]
up her perfect sister he talks mess
behind her back starts running an
illegal game of cards kick up a storm
demanding to watch the World Series and
even Jack's a boat so the whole Posse
can get their fishing game on the Nurse
Ratched don't play man
and she bout had it with McMurphy's
bullsh she's strapped him to a bed and
give him electroshock treatment straight
to the dog
damn girl that's harsh it ain't all bad
though McMurphy's [ __ ] the man attitude
a surprise to other homies the stars
sticking up for themselves even chief
shows his real self to Mack and soon
enough they become real tight later
McMurphy decide to go hard in the paint
and sneak two holes into the joint
so his boy Billy can lose his cherry
everybody having a good old time
drinking on some liquor popping pills
and sippin on some sizzurp they got from
the farmers ID everybody pass the [ __ ]
out Nurse Ratched walks in on a complete
show Billy got that goofy ass smile on
his face now that he met it but when
ratchet threatens to tell his mama that
her boy been sticking his digging some
strange brother wigs out and slices his
own throat damn he did after ratchet try
to blame McMurphy for Billy's suicide
Matt goes hyphy and straight chunks of
[ __ ] oh yeah and he rips her dress open
and um Teddy stop bouncing all over the
place it's in the book man he don't kill
her but girl is [ __ ] up and can't
speak for weeks getting crunk on Nurse
Ratched like that make the law come down
on Mack har they strap him to the table
again and give him a lobotomy now he
ain't nothing more than a mile asami
but she don't want to see his boy go out
like that people need to remember him as
the righteous gangster he was not this
busted ass thing that's been broken by
the system haters can't win so she puts
a pillow all the McMurphy's face and go
sir
but we love you know then brother lifts
the heaviest [ __ ] control panel and cuts
it out of the window and busts his ass
out of that institution
when this book hit the streets in the
1960s dark was going down and asylums on
the rag patients getting whupped on
humiliated and put on a short leash like
being nothing but dogs when you treat it
like less than human how the hell you're
gonna survive when you get out ain't got
the [ __ ] point of getting treatment
nobody better representing this crooked
bullsh then one of the biggest ball
breakers in all the lid game Nurse
Ratched e ratchet you're committed you
realize you are under the jurisdiction
of me the staff she's holding up a fist
all those red orange fingernails burning
it to her palm under jurisdiction and
control girl flexing her authority like
a straight-up dig team she force his
homies to take pills they don't want to
take she scheduled every minute of their
lives
man she even got a lock on what go on
inside their heads instead of building a
brother up she just break them down so
they can't even function outside the
system their bunk a situation best
represented by that big hydro console
that thing's so damn heavy there ain't
no chance it's going anywhere just like
them boys ain't never gonna leave this
trap cuz that system laying down on
their confidence like a ball and chain
but when Mac roll up on the spot he take
a big old dump on ratchets gang by
trying to lift that console both
metaphorically and on a real see he's
trying to convince these cats that they
don't need some [ __ ] hag with giant
tits
tell them they broken and they need to
be controlled naw blood they got the
juice to control their own lives they
just need someone like Mac they give him
the confidence to buck ratchets crooked
sister when she trunks that big console
out the window he do just that he
liberates them from the mental bullsh
that's been weighing them down for years
the scariest thing is though this
ratchet-ass nerds don't need no muscle
to flex like a dictator nah this girl's
most gangster weapon is her voice her
soft [ __ ] floors enough to make her
brothers nuts shrivel up the razors what
makes it so dangerous is that she able
to front like she being pleasant but on
a real she controlling these homies like
the nasty is a bug
so when Matt takes her boys away for a
couple of weeks I have to choking her
out it's like he taken away her Power
Man
ratchet his two gangster to just sit
back and take it she gets back in back
by taking away his power the ability to
inspire confidence and freedom in the
boys but chief don't let it go down like
that
by killing Mack before everyone see them
all whacked out in the head chief allows
max message to live on the system might
be able to break a man but they can't
break an idea max sacrificing himself to
inspire other homeys may come straight
Jesus like for one when he take the
brothers on a fishing trip there's 12 of
them just like Jesus and his 12 apostles
and just check these quotes when he bout
to get zapped anointest my head with
conducted do I get a crown of thorns you
are strapped to a table shaped
ironically like a cross with a crown of
electric sparks in place of thorns yeah
it sounds like McMurphy's are pretty
righteous dude but is it for real
does he really want the men to grow
bigger balls and stand up for themselves
does he just like deal with people after
all just play a lot about being cray
just so he could dodge hard labor so we
know he ain't the most Jesus like dude
maybe Mac doesn't give a [ __ ] about the
others maybe he just liked the starch so
we ain't born we may not have nut houses
that do you like this anymore but I
don't mean we free from that kind of
mental control these days we told that
any problem can be solved by just
popping a pill if you got something that
normal about you then you're sick and
you gotta be treated so as any real
progress been made since this book hit
the streets have we really broken out of
these crooked institutions are we all
just living in a bigger institution hmm
yo thanks for kicking me with your boy
man
yeah thanks for keeping it with me and
if you're looking to build a fly website
to shop your skills you started all our
business I just share your ideas and
creations head on over the
squarespace.com
it means we make the website you want
and then that turns of a war winning my
template to help you get started you
don't need to know coding or anything
and then giving all ul red ball is ten
percent off your first order then you
use the offer code if that ain't good
enough square spaces hook y'all up with
a free 14-day trial so you can see for
yourself just how easy it is so go to
Squarespace comm slash thug notes or use
the link in the description below and
sign up today and you'll get a free 14
day trial to test it out be sure to use
the offer code thug notes to get 10% off
your thanks to Squarespace for being a
homie and sponsoring this video and
we've got lots more videos on the way so
click here to go to our channel page and
if you haven't already make sure to
subscribe while you're there
catch y'all next time peace